public sénat
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver à
suivre ce matin sur public sénat à
partir de 11h en direct les voeux de
martine aubry alors que les socialistes
se sont enfin mis d'accord sur un
calendrier pour les primaires mais tout
de suite c'est un débat sénatorial dans
l'hémicycle sur la ruralité
aujourd'hui 50% des français vivant à la
campagne
il faut dire que le secteur rural
représente 80 % de la superficie
française mais cette ruralité est elle
une chance pour l'avenir et la cohésion
des territoires
c'est à cette question que les sénateurs
vont tenter de répondre il interroge ce
matin dans le cadre de leurs actions de
contrôle du gouvernement le ministre
bruno le maire ministre de l'agriculture
un débat qui intervient quasiment un an
jour pour jour après le discours de
nicolas sarkozy prononcé à morée où le
président de la république s'était
engagé en faveur du monde rural à très
bonne séance à tous la science est
ouverte le compte-rendu analytique de la
précédente séance et distribue n'ya pas
d'observation le procès verbal est
adoptée sur les réserves d'usagé l'ordre
du jour appelle la discussion des
questions avec débat numéro 2 de
monsieur didier guillaume monsieur mise
agriculture de l'alimentation de la
pêche de hérité de la maison du
territoire sur la ruralité une chance
pour la cohésion et l'avenir des
territoires
la parole était didier guillaume un
auteur de la question
c'est la deuxième
mais un merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes très chers
collègues le thème de cette question
orale avec débat c'est la ruralité
une chance pour la cohésion et l'avenir
des territoires
une ministre le monde rural est au coeur
de notre culture de notre identité
collective de notre patrimoine national
que ce soit en littérature des paysans
de balzac jusqu'à la terre de zola en
peinture de monet à giverny à van gogh
dépeignant sa provence adoptive il n'a
cessé d'exalter le génie artistique le
monde rural à irriguer la france de ses
valeurs de solidarité
son implication dans la résistance
suffit à démontrer le lien inaltérable
qui l'unît à notre pays comme dans le
vercors le limousin où l'ensemble des
maquis de notre république
aujourd'hui la ruralité ne semble pas
être une priorité politique pour l'état
les citoyens du monde rural se sentent
délaissés il regarde jour après jour
leurs services publics fermés la
république les abandonner aujourd'hui
des millions de citoyens sont en bois
d'exclusion de notre pacte républicain
l'égalité territoriale est bafouée ils
ont un accès limité aux services publics
de base la mise en oeuvre de la rgpp a
accentué le phénomène
la pénurie des moyens de l'état la
logique purement comptable et de très
court terme font énormément de dégâts il
ya urgence à agir
notre pays tout entier est concerné par
la ruralité le monde rural se
métamorphosent loin d'être ringard
ils constituent de formidables potentiel
de développement il n'est pas replié sur
lui-même
ils avancent les femmes et des hommes
qui y vivent se bat inlassablement sur
le terrain pour un quotidien meilleur
j'ai bon espoir qu'un avenir mais qu un
avenir meilleur choix possible
un avenir fait de cohésion sociale et de
cohésion territoriale
quand on est artisan boulanger à
chomérac ain ardèche
ostréiculteur à aurait dans le morbihan
producteurs de foie gras pomarez dans
les landes
propriétaire d'un gîte à ribérac en
dordogne infirmière à valréas dans le
vaucluse assistantes maternelles à
guéret dans la creuse directeur d'un
site de production du leader mondial du
luxe lvmh à marsa dans la drôme salariés
d'un parc naturel à saint-etienne de
tinée dans le mercantour de la poste à
aguessac dans l'aveyron plombier à
florac en lozère
mes deux seins raon l'étape dans les
vosges patron d'une scierie à campan
dans les hautes-pyrénées chirurgien a
dit ou pdg des porcelaines revol à
saint-uze salariés d'un parc aventure à
langogne en lozère ou restaurateurs
comme régis marcon à
saint-bonnet-le-froid michel sabra apens
de l'isère les frères ibarboure à bidart
ou encore arrambide à saint jean pied de
port
oui yves jouanny à la remise à un trek
sur volane les réalités de vie sont les
mêmes le fait rural le monde rural est
un moteur de développement notamment
économiques
il n'est pas concevable que ses
habitants soient considérés comme des
citoyens low cost
confronté aux pires difficultés
concernant l'accès aux services publics
primordiaux comme la santé ou
l'éducation
il n'est pas compréhensible que la
fracture numérique s'accentue il n'est
pas acceptable que la question des
transports nuit encore à la vigueur
économique de ces territoires
nous voulons un aménagement du
territoire harmoniser et nous devons
définir ensemble quelles sont les
conditions indispensables au
développement des zones rurales pour que
ces territoires participent à construire
la france du xxième siècle les habitants
du monde rural wii ont des difficultés
pour accéder aux services publics
primordiaux comme la santé qui doit être
une priorité
les déserts médicaux fleurissent
aujourd'hui dans nos campagnes et nos
montagnes
l'urgence actuelle est de recouvrer un
haut degré de proximité
l'absence d'offre médical et de
permanence des soins sur une bonne
partie du territoire français prive des
pans entiers de notre société de l'accès
aux soins les délais pour accéder
soins met en danger les patients si l'on
ajoute à ce tableau la fermeture
progressive d'urgence de maternité de
bloc opératoire on peut situer sans
peine le degré d'abandon dans lequel se
trouve actuellement le monde rural
la loi hpst a failli plus de 18 mois
après son adoption
rien n'a changé a dit dans la drôme
c'est la croix et la bannière pour
trouver un chirurgien
car le service d'urgence et la maternité
sont menacés et je ne vous parle même
pas de l'hôpital de valréas dans
vaucluse des hôpitaux de proximité
d'union ses buis les baronnies
en ardèche la maternité de saint-agrève
a fermé en octobre 2008
les femmes enceintes doivent aller jusqu
à ânonner 60 km plus loin dans les côtes
d'armor à paimpol l'hôpital n'a plus
d'activité depuis le mois de janvier à
doullens dans la somme après avoir perdu
le bloc opératoire l'été dernier c'est
la maternité qui est aujourd'hui menacée
et la liste des inquiétudes est longue
figeac dans le lot decazeville dans
l'aveyron gisors dans l'eure le doute
qui pèse sur les urgences les blocs
opératoires et les maternités conduit
les hôpitaux de proximité à avoir
mauvaise presse les citoyens à avoir
moins confiance
les personnels à chercher un avenir
ailleurs le débat sur les hôpitaux un
fort impact sur la présence des médecins
généralistes et quand l'hôpital est le
premier employeur de la ville comme à
buis-les-baronnies petites communes
rurales plus d'hôpital ce serait à moyen
terme 150 familles en moins pour les
commerçants les artisans et pour les
écoles il faut donc changer la norme
changer les normes le maintien en réseau
de ces structures est tout à fait viable
de plus il est vital il en va de la
sécurité de nos concitoyens
après la santé l'éducation est une
exigence parce que l'accès à l'éducation
est impérative chaque nouvelle année
scolaire possède son lot de fermetures
de classes
les moyens humains mis à disposition de
ces territoires semble se déliter
l'égalité des chances c'est le socle de
notre république
quand des écoles de la république fait
en ce sont les fondations de notre idéal
républicain qui s'effondre l'éducation
et la santé sont les symboles de cette
république qui fuit ses responsabilités
dans nos campagnes
mais que penser lorsque des bureaux de
poste ferme privant les citoyens d'un
moyen de communication que penser
lorsque des gendarmeries ferme privant
les habitants du monde rural d'un
service régalien
que penser lorsque les tribunaux ferment
sinon que la justice française
fonctionne à deux vitesses
que penser du débat sur le maintien des
sous préfectures
alors même que ces dernières maillent le
territoire de l'action administrative de
proximité
que penser du passage à la tnt qui
inquiète les élus et les citoyens
avec le risque en écrits d'un écran noir
dans certaines zones mais après ce
constat qui peut paraître noir voire
négatif deux secteurs clés du
développement rural sont importantes je
voudrais aborder maintenant les
transports et la communication
du point de vue des transports beaucoup
de paramètres structurels sont à
améliorer
en matière d'infrastructures
ferroviaires notamment aujourd'hui
l'inégalité de desserte est un grand et
stable
michel destot on en parlera tout à
l'heure l'entretien et le développement
des routes et des autoroutes devrait
être assurée afin de permettre le
désenclavement de tous les territoires
et j'ai entendu les normes heureuse
intervention du président de la
république sur ce sujet la mise en
chantier du dernier tronçon autoroutier
clairement béziers est un signe
important au désenclavement nos
territoires
il est désormais prioritaire qu'il en
soit de même pour la liaison grenoble
sisteron l'implantation d'entreprises la
dynamisation du tissu économique dépend
notamment de la qualité de la desserte
par la route les transports collectifs
sont essentiels
garant d'un meilleur développement
durable réduisant les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre et puis le numérique est
une chance historique pour l'aménagement
du territoire
ce n'est pas seulement une révolution
technologique notre collègue hervé morel
a évoqué dans son excellent rapport
c'est une formidable opportunité pour
réorienter l'économie vers le savoir et
la connaissance le développement de la
fibre optique dans le cadre du plan
national très haut débit
constitue un nouveau tournant les
collectivités territoriales se sont
massivement engagés dans cette voie car
elle est synonyme d'aménagement du
territoire de modernité et de progrès la
ruralité à très haut débit
oui voilà le défi qui nous attend la
ruralité à très haut débit et l'état
doit accompagner les collectivités
à ce titre il faut regretter la récente
décision gouvernementale qui supprime la
dotation de 25 millions d'euros dédié
aux écoles numériques rurales la fibre
peut mettre le rural sur un total pied
d'égalité avec l'urbain par exemple
plutôt que de fermer une perception aux
zones rurales pour concentrer son
activité dans la ville voisine
grâce au haut débit ne serait-il pas
possible de la maintenir et du donné par
du thé les trois travail et par le haut
débit les du travail pour désengorger
les postes comptables des grandes villes
c'est un exemple il y en a beaucoup
d'autres et cela maintiendrait la
présence des services en zone rurale
j'ai la conviction que le champ des
possibles est immense mais au-delà de
ces constats la ruralité est un
véritable moteur de développement
durable agricole économique culturel et
social de notre pays
la ruralité se définit d'abord par son
économie agricole monsieur le ministre
aujourd'hui les agriculteurs souffrent
aucune filière n'est épargné et même si
selon l'insee le ministère
le revenu annuel moyen agricole
s'établit en 2010 à meynes 4400 euros
contre 14 mille six cent en 2009 soit
une progression incontestable de plus de
60%
ces chiffres doivent être placés dans le
contexte de la crise 7 l'os est en fait
une hausse en trompe-l'oeil réel pour
cette année mais elle fait suite à une
baisse cumulée de plus de 50% des
revenus agricoles
aucune autre profession n'aurait
supporter cela et je veux rendre hommage
aux agriculteurs de notre pays
lors de l'examen de la lm ap en mai
dernier monsieur le ministre vous
prononciez cette phrase je ne saurais
trop insister sans régulation le marché
agricole européen ne sera pas diable il
est sans doute trop tôt pour établir le
bilan de cette loi sur certains points
comme le
forcément de la contractualisation la
création de l'observatoire des prix et
des marges ou encore la définition d'une
véritable politique alimentaire
nationale
nous pouvons nous retrouver la
régulation le nouveau maître mot de
cette loi n'est pas encore réellement
entrer en vigueur oui l'agriculture
française est viable et aptes à nourrir
les français grâce à une alimentation de
qualité mais pour que notre agriculture
est un avenir
il faut mieux protéger le foncier
agricole face à l'artificialisation
renouveler les générations en installant
deux jeunes agriculteurs mettre en place
des circuits courts permettant aux
agriculteurs de mieux vivre de leur
production et aux consommateurs
d'acheter des produits de qualité à des
prix abordables
il y a urgence si nous croyons encore à
l'agriculture française
mais l'agriculture je le disais n'est
pas le seul moteur économique de la
réalité car l'économie rurale tire sa
richesse de sa diversité
ce sont aussi les milliers de
commerçants d'artisans d'entrepreneurs
qui exercent dans nos territoires il ne
faut pas les négliger surtout en terme
d'emploi car ces entreprises là ne sont
pas délocalisables
sans elle dans certaines sont
prestigieuses et leaders dans leur
domaine d'activité le monde rural
n'aurait pas ce potentiel important dans
mon département
l'entreprise délit fruits à marchès
l'entreprise skf aerospace à saint
vallier qui fait de la mécanique de
haute précision pour la nasa et eads
l'entreprise lafuma que tout le monde
connaît le chocolatier val roma à tain
l'hermitage les papeteries de monségur
premier fabricant français de papier de
soie le claude accusant à saint-aubin
sur ouvèze sanoflore centre de recherche
du groupe l'oréal agi gorée los van van
hattum qui équipe les centrales
nucléaires en robinetterie les revit du
diois à châtillon leurs chefs
d'entreprise et leurs salariés font
vivre nos villages ils sont attachés à
leur territoire ils innovent et leurs
enfants sont dans nos écoles tous les
sénateurs pourrait dresser le même
portrait de leur territoire il ya de
grandes entreprises dans la creuse
comme à nice à guéret spécialisé dans le
secteur de la force dans les pyrénées
atlantiques comme turbomeca leader
mondial des turbines d'hélicoptères
cette diversité économique est en tout
cas vital pour notre pays
sans elle
pas de maillage économique de la france
le rôle joué par l'économie sociale et
solidaire est également important basé
sur des principes d'égalité de
responsabilité et de démocratie
elle propose une autre façon
d'entreprendre et de créer
il faut encourager le développement des
activités économiques et solidaires
notamment les métiers à potentiel de
développement de main d'oeuvre en faveur
des personnes peu qualifiées
indispensable mais pourront elles encore
fonctionner avec la baisse des crédits
de l'état et la baisse des contrats
aidés dans bon nombre de départements
ruraux le secteur de l'aide à domicile
est tout simplement le premier employeur
du territoire je veux saluer ces
associations indispensable au lien
social les admr aide à domicile en
milieu rural les familles rurales les
maisons sociales comme celle de cure
nier ou encore vivre et vieillir au
village à puy saint martin ils assurent
le lien social pour accompagner
notamment les personnes âgées et
handicapées
mais au delà encore le bouillonnement
culturel et social la ruralité en est
synonyme il ya des symboles qui rayonne
à l'échelle nationale les vieilles
charrues à carhaix
jazz in marciac les fêtes nocturnes de
grignan
le festival international du film
fantastique à gérardmer et de nombreux
autres sur chaque territoire surtout nos
territoires
le monde associatif est porté par des
passionnés d'une incroyable vitalité
club sport culture troisième âge c'est
un véritable bouillonnement culturel et
social qui permet de construire le lien
le vivre ensemble
voilà ce qui attire les citoyens nos
campagnes monsieur le ministre c'est un
mélange d'authenticité de qualité de vie
mais aussi et surtout le dynamisme
l'inventivité l'innovation perpétuelle
les potentialités de se réaliser de
créer de la richesse économique social
et culturel
le monde rural est bien en pointe sur
l'innovation ses habitants ses chefs
d'entreprise ces commerçants ses
artisans ses bénévoles associatifs des
élus attendent non pas qu'on leur donne
toujours plus de moyens il compte
souvent plus sur eux mêmes que sur les
autres en revanche ils attendent qu'on
leur garantisse les conditions
nécessaires à leur épanouissement et à
leur développement se priver de ce
potentiel de développement c'est couper
la france en deux fermes et un hôpital
une école ne pas construire les routes
du numérique dans les territoires ruraux
c'est peut-être une économie comptable
mais s'est posé une hypothèque sur notre
avenir commun et se priver d'une chance
bien réels dont la france aura besoin
pour construire son avenir pour ne pas
poser d'hypothèque sur notre avenir
il est nécessaire de contrer de
concrétiser le principe d'équité
territoriale et de se mettre d'accord
sur les services de base dont les zones
rurales ont besoin le monde rural ne
saurait être opposée à l'urbain un
aménagement du territoire harmoniser ses
la recherche permanente d'un équilibre
territorial entre le rural et l'urbain
je dirais même que l'un ne peut aller
sans l'autre dans la réflexion au sein
de ce débat le mot de cohésion me semble
essentiel c'est en effet le résultat
recherché dans cette enquête permanente
d'équilibré l'état un rôle central à
jouer en matière d'aménagement du
territoire
mais je crains que la création du
conseiller territorial ne soit un très
mauvais signe l'état détient des legré
d'aménagement de développement
il doit se réengager aux côtés des
collectivités territoriales pour le
développement des territoires ruraux
il doit accompagner la mutation que nous
voyons au quotidien il doit être en
mesure de garantir les fondamentaux d'un
développement équilibré
il faut une volonté politique forte le
bouclier rural que nous voulons
instaurer témoigne de ces difficultés
croissantes le bouclier rural c'est la
mise en place d'une politique
volontariste qui place le principe
d'équité territoriale au sommet de nos
valeurs le bouclier rural
c'est tout simplement la défense et la
promotion des services publics le
gouvernement devrait s'engager dans
cette voie
il existe aujourd'hui de nombreux outils
d'aménagement les intercommunalités les
parcs et les pays à l'instar des
contrats urbains de cohésion sociale
ne pourrait-on pas exploré la création
des contrats ruraux de cohésion
territoriale
il s'agirait tout simplement de définir
sur des aires géographiques définies les
services communs qui doivent être
accessibles à tous en tenant compte des
distances à parcourir et le tueur est
important de déterminer la carte de tous
les services de base sur deux un temps
d'accès garanti jeu conclut monsieur le
président
les défis que rencontre le monde rural
sont nombreux plusieurs questions se
posent aujourd'hui le gouvernement est
il prêt à réinvestir la ruralité comme
entente il serait engagée aux côtés des
collectivités etc ils prêts à mener une
politique volontariste à l'égard de ces
zones pour réduire la facture tirer la
fracture territoriale
aujourd'hui notre pays souffre de ce
déséquilibre pesant mais vous l'avez vu
la ruralité les élus les associations
les chefs d'entreprise tous les jours se
battent sont positifs sont optimistes
parce qu'elle incarne aujourd'hui une
nouvelle forme de modernité sociale et
territoriale
j'ai confiance en la ruralité j'ai
confiance en son formidable potentiel de
développement économique et social pour
notre pays tout entier
la ruralité est porteuse de perspectives
et de cohésion j'ai la conviction
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
que la ruralité est une chance pour la
cohésion et l'avenir de notre nation
tout entière je vous remercie
merci collègues dans le débat la parole
n'était jean boyer pour l'union
centriste
c'est vraiment
winch est président et ses ministres mes
chers collègues
constatant collectivement et je dis très
franchement que didier guillaume connaît
parfaitement la france rurale et j'ai
essayé de transposer dans mon esprit des
différents points qu'il a évoqué sa
collègue monsieur le ministre la france
d'après-guerre comme vous le savez
compter 40 millions d'habitants 20% été
localisé en vie des 80 % en zone rurale
aujourd'hui la répartissant la
répartition pardon est diamétralement
opposée cependant certains territoires
ruraux connaissent un regain
d'attractivité qu'il faut soutenir il
faut soutenir leurs espérances et de
râteaux je dirais avant qu'il trouve
qu'on n'est qu'en fois face à des
territoires sans hommes je suis dans un
département où il ya un canton qui a
moins de cinq habitants kg au mètre
carré il doit y en avoir d'autres un an
après les conclusions des assises de la
ruralité
il me semble opportun le ministre de
rappeler trois éléments fondamentaux
premièrement l'avenir des territoires
ruraux passe nécessairement par une
diversification de l'économie
aujourd'hui encore trop limitée à
l'agriculture surtout chers collègues
si on l'a seulement à cette agriculture
une mission de production brute sans lui
permettre de la valoriser un exemple
dans mon département suit la haute loire
en 1990 sur 34 mille tonnes de viande
bovine ou ovine produite
vingt-huit mille tonnes étaient abattus
dans l'es7 abattoirs locaux
aujourd'hui il reste un abattoir avec
3500 tonnes
nous n'allons pas dans le souhait de
selon map les circuits courts dans la
dernière éléments ni de la valorisation
in situ des productions il faudrait donc
monsieur le ministre le vrai pour ancrer
et pérenniser territorialement les
entreprises disponibles et des
dispositifs pour les pôles d'excellence
rurale reconnaissons europe
reconnaissant le positif ont contribué à
soutenir à ancrer les entrepreneurs
ruraux mais cela n'est pas suffisant
reconnaissant que les psys prc positif
parce qu'ils sont des soutiens de
projets pas des soutiens de guichet en
outre monsieur le ministre le
millefeuille des dispositifs d'appui
économique des structures
administratives freine vraiment vraiment
les projets certains se découragent et
ne vont pas jusqu'au bout donc
améliorons la souplesse la simplicité et
la proximité entre la fonction
économique la ruralité assure une
fonction résidentielle dopé par une
mobilité croissante et la recherche
qualité de vie qu'on ne trouve pas dans
les villes mais la solidarité doit être
objective elle doit être comprise
elle doit être sans sans démagogie
compenser seulement l'extension urbaine
et le mitage des campagnes constituent
un danger de sur consommation des
espaces agricoles passant comme vous le
savez monsieur le ministre de 35 mille
hectares de terrains d'école consommés
chaque année dans les années soixante à
soixante quinze mille aujourd'hui
j'espère que la mise en place de
l'observatoire de la consommation des
espaces agricoles jouera pleinement son
rôle de régulateur et favorisera la
réhabilitation d'anciennes bâtisses
bâtisse plutôt qu'un mythe agen contrôlé
à des maisons à 100 mille euros
il faut quand même garder il faut que la
ruralité garder l'image de son
patrimoine et il ne faut pas qu'il y ait
des lotissements délocaliser et qui
dénature le contexte général
si je considère ces trois fonctions
comme on se plante pardon il faut
désormais voir quelles sont les mesures
qui permettent au monde rural de les
remplir pour le mieux
parce que deux territoires parce que
deux territoires ont des problématiques
différentes
il faut impérativement des approches
différentes et donc donné aux élus
locaux et notamment aux régions des
marges de manoeuvre accrues en termes
financiers les collectivités des zones
rurales sont au bord de l'asphyxié
puisque d'un côté 1 n'ont qu'un faible
potentiel fiscal du fait de la faiblesse
de leur faible densité
alors que la taille de leur territoire
engendre un surcroît important pour
l'entretien des réseaux des voiries et
de l'assainissement ses ministres ça ne
date pas d'aujourd'hui étant à un
responsable ricol est très modestement
rural j'ai toujours pensé que dans les
dotations de l'état on devait prendre en
compte
je dirais pas seulement les hommes mais
les espaces à gérer si je prends une
commune de 100 habitants elle peut être
localisé dans une copropriété où il ya
le parking la station d'épuration et je
dirais c'est tout aujourd'hui dans une
commune de 200 habitants il ya souvent
20 à 30 km de voirie il y à des ouvrages
il ya des équipements d'eau ou aux
sanitaires
donc il faut je crois prendre cet espace
à gérer et encourager toutes les aînés
toutes les initiatives des territoires
ruraux
je crois que c'est ainsi à leur donnant
leur chance par les par les per ou
d'autres initiatives dont donc on leur
donnera lé envie de rester au pays d'y
vivre et de pouvoir y vivre
merci monsieur le ministre merci
monsieur collègues la parole et
jean-jacques closer pour le groupe
socialiste
c'est vrai que cela
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
tout d'abord une évidence toute forme de
recentralisation des fonctions
collective et préjudiciable aux intérêts
de la ruralité
car appauvrissant une relation de
proximité par exemple entre les services
déconcentrés de l'état et les citoyens
ou bien entre les élus les citoyens une
relation de proximité indispensable au
mieux vivre collectif des personnes
concernées or la récente réforme
territoriale tout comme la rgpp et
génératrice de distanciation de perte de
sens du mandat électif pour les
élections régionales et départementales
au bénéfice notamment des représentants
de l'état avec notamment le transfert de
certaines missions ou bien encore la
méthode qui préside ou redécoupage des
cantons et au schéma départemental de
coopération intercommunale
prenons l'exemple du département cette
année sera celle du 140e anniversaire de
la loi du 10 août 1871 principale loi
organisant la vie l'assemblée
départementale avant les lois de
décentralisation de 82 83 pour ce 140e
anniversaire le conseil général comme
collectivités locales ne méritent ils
pas mieux que la soumission à une
attente inquiète celle de sa probable
disparition
à l'issue d'une phase transitoire
personnalisé par le conseiller
territorial
pour notre part nous ne cessons de
vanter les mérites en milieu rural d'un
échange départemental de proximité de
solidarité pour nos concitoyens mais
également de repères et d' équilibre
dans une mondialisation qui ne cessent
de gagner du terrain
d'ailleurs la rgpp le démantèlement des
services publics la fragilisation des
conseils généraux et régionaux
derrière la réforme territoriale y at il
une vision historique de l'organisation
territoriale de la république et du
futur de la ruralité
non nous constatons une simple logique
comptable de réduction brutale des
effectifs et des dépenses sans
anticipation de l'avenir et avec une
incompréhensible uniformisation des
décisions ainsi se multiplient
aveuglément les restructuration
judiciaire militaire
scolaire hospitalière ainsi dans mon
département la creuse vient temps de
fermer l'unique service de radiothérapie
obligeant des patients souvent gravement
malade en parcourir plus d'une heure de
route pour trouver un service de cette
nature au moment le cancer devient la
première cause de mortalité en france
dans notre pays c'est l'état qui a
construit la nation et la déliquescence
de l'accès pour tous à des services
publics comme la santé l'éducation la
sécurité
amy est le socle de notre république et
les valeurs de protection et d'équité
qu'elle représente
il en est de même avec la suppression de
la taxe professionnelle et son
corollaire la coupure du lien entre
l'entreprise et son territoire en toute
politique nationale indifférente odien
charnelle entre l'homme son territoire
sa production et sa culture s'avérera
mortifère pour la dignité de nos
terroirs et de ceux qui les habitent
elle est ignorante des shows de la
campagne et bêtement méprisante pour une
prétendue france profonde qui ne se
situent pas toujours là où on croit
oui le monde rural est bien plus vivant
et plus complexe que ce qu'imaginent
certaines administrations
il est surtout capable de prendre en
main son destin dès lors qu'on ne crée
pas les conditions de sa résignation
demain et on en voit déjà certaines
prémices les conséquences sociales
humaines financières les conséquences
sanitaires psychologiques sécuritaires
environnementales de l'hyper
concentration urbaine seront tels que la
ruralité sera de plus en plus désirer et
sollicité c'est cette appréhension de la
société de demain que nous devons
anticiper dès aujourd'hui la ruralité
peut être une chance pour la france
si certaines conditions sont remplies
avec une politique ambitieuse globale
transversale intégrant ses spécificités
dans les schémas nationaux des
infrastructures un régime dérogatoire
pour les services publics une attention
spécifique au réseau des pme pmi une
reconnaissance majeure des zones
d'élevage dans les déclinaisons
budgétaire de la future pac une action
plus forte face aux menaces de fracture
numérique le maintien du dispositif
analogue au zrr
mais spatialement plus concentré une
attention déterminé portée aux
conditions d'accueil de nouvelles
populations et d'activités ou bien
encore la création d'une véritable
cinquième branche de la sécurité sociale
concernant le risque de dépendance pour
des personnes âgées nombreuses sur ces
espaces là en période de crise il est
impératif d'apporter plus à ceux qui en
ont le plus besoin
cela vaut aussi pour les territoires
l'urgence est un que nous devons aller
plus loin que les simples appels à
candidatures pour per par ailleurs la
baisse de 14% des moyens d'intervention
de la datar en 2011 n'est pas de nature
à rassurer les porteurs de projets un
aménagement du territoire mérite d'être
une priorité nationale la population
étant d'ores et déjà hyper concentré sur
20% la superficie de notre pays
ce que je ne considère nullement comme
un progrès de civilisation
le face à face est à métropole va
laisser tous les espaces interstitiels
abandonné au chacun pour soi
nous regrettons également que le dernier
remaniement ministériel et conduit à la
dilution la ruralité dans un grand
ministère fourre-tout non complétée par
un ministère délégué ou un secrétariat
d'état spécifique
il nous faut mais ce mini une grande loi
sur développement des territoires ruraux
porté par une idée légitimes exprimées à
travers l'expression bouclier rural
comportant notamment le maintien ou le
rétablissement du service public
indispensable à la cohésion sociale
oui la ruralité est riche de virtualité
d'attenté d'exigence aussi l'état mais
également l'europe doit qu'il l'aider à
choisir le meilleur d'elle-même en
jouant tous ces cartes avec
détermination
merci mon cher collègue la parole et à
robert tropéano pour le groupe rdse
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues la ruralité
à l'aube tanit est associée à la seule
activité agricole est perçu comme un
espace périphériques c'est plus de
loisirs ou de vacances et à une vaste
réserve foncière au service d'une
urbanisation et d'un aménagement
réfléchi après un déclin certaine elle
connaît un renouveau depuis une dizaine
d'années avec notamment voilà nous
interrompons la séance pour une matinée
de voeux politiques sur les chaînes
parlementaires
dans quelques instants vous pourrez
suivre les voeux de jean luc mélenchon
le président du parti de gauche prononcé
il ya tout juste quelques minutes mais
d'abord place au direct vous allez
écouter à les voeux de martine aubry la
première secrétaire du parti socialiste
elle va tracer la feuille de route du
parti pour 2011
on les écoute tout de suite c'est en
direct de la rue de solférino